now among those waiting at the airport
is nissa he's a translator who worked
for the british and french french
militaries and he's taught english to
women and girls we're trying to get him
on the phone nissa can you hear me
nissan can you hear me it's kimberly the
sky news anchor
uh
i can hear you
okay thank you nissa nissa how long have
you been there and where exactly are you
uh ma'am currently i'm just uh
inside the clouds
putting
behind the uh
the gate
i
i'm just behind the car at the gear of
the barren hotel working here for almost
uh four days that has been four days
i've been waiting uh over here
do you have the documentation do you
have a visa for the uk are you able to
come to the uk
uh yes i've got the email i've i do have
my documentations with me i've got the
email uh from the home office and they
uh directed me to visit
the
uh baron hotel
and
uh to get
to the gate and
and and to complete my
documents clearance
process and
the next
step i i move
forward to my uh status surface but
still i can't i
still i didn't hear anything any news
and i'm waiting and then uh
taking this time and
i can hold this i've been working here
with my long while with my mother
who is also
sick and she had health issues
and the situation is also not good and
the cars are rushing over here
yeah
if i understand correctly you have an
email saying that you should go to the
hotel there to complete your
documentation you've been there for four
days and you are with your mother who is
not well
have you spoken to any uk official any
nato official any official at all
about getting on a flight
uh well unfortunately i've got almost a
couple of uh calls i've got it from the
uh from the end and almost responds
but since then i haven't received any
calls i haven't received any contacts or
any messages any messages from there at
their side
and i'm then
waiting and controlling to
hear something from this and i've been
trying to get in touch with somebody but
unfortunately the guards uh
uh outside the door and decide to get
they're not letting us to
yeah talk with him to communicate with
them or to get in touch with any british
army or
with the
employees inside who deals with the
process
who is who is guarding that gate nissa
uh uh the kids where i'm located and
where i'm waiting for uh they have been
guarding by the local
uh local afghans local governors they
love canada
it's not taliban and
we know but this is local
afghan guys i mean the local
citizens who live uh
around this area their houses are around
this area okay
okay nasa what are you going to do now
well ma'am
exactly i i i don't know what to do but
all i'm doing is
to wait and just wait and see
um if i can hear in the next minute or
maybe
so uh
also uh to hear
the
to hear my name announced on the
loudspeaker so i can get inside and i
complete my process but i'm all all i
can do for now is just to wait here
along with my mother
and just uh trying to stay away
from the most crowds who are rushing and
they're hurting people many people have
been uh died especially the children and
the uh eldest people
so i'm trying uh to be a little bit away
from them and
i'm sitting in a safe in a corner place
and i'm just near the loudspeaker i can
hear
the names are falling
beside if you do not get on a flight if
you and your mom do not get on a flight
are you worried for your safety are you
going to be in danger
i've been already uh i've been already
trust a couple of times and i've been
receiving faith from taliban side
and uh
my house were uh searched uh twice as i
heard from my family members
the the account and they were looking
they were looking forward
on
situation and you don't know what will
happen in the next minute uh for you
especially
with people with afghans like me who
have been
as a transfer and
works as an english teacher and educated
uh
women especially
so
don't know
if i do
opportunity to to get done
i'm not sure
how long it will take so
that they will find me and they will
attack anything
i saved the trades
even
mentioned they will uh catch me soon and
they will defeat me and
they will uh cut my tongue and uh
and also
they will do any brutal
crucially telling to me as they did
uh recently to a few of my best friends
and my colleagues i lost my colleagues
and
my village and some of my very good
friends i've lost
yeah
okay um nissa thank you so much for
talking to us um we wish you luck and we
do hope that you hear your name on that
loudspeaker and you do get on a flight
thank you for talking to us nasa